out of the blue a wartime leader on an
extraordinary surprise mission
president zielinski was greeted by Rishi
sunak a prime minister he's still
getting to know
but on the drive-in time to discuss
Ukraine's deepening conflict zelenski's
advisors say a massive new Russian
offensive could now be just weeks away
as the extraordinary welcome showed in
Downey Street Ukraine's leader is
preaching to the choir here he's here he
says to say thank you thank you for
inviting me and for many great honor to
be here
but also to say his country needs much
more
in the grand Majesty of Westminster Hall
a hero's welcome by both houses of
Parliament
props and a royal reference to press
home his point his country needs more
help in the air in Britain the king
is a near Force pilot
and in Ukraine today
every year Force pilot is a king
the parliament today
thanking all of you in advance
for powerful English planes
it's because he believes time is running
out
it felt like an impromptu State visit
squeezed into a day
after an audience with the King a chance
to see the latest help his Majesty's
forces are giving Ukraine we've all been
worried about you thinking about your
country oh my God
Challenger battle tax and training for
Pilots to fly NATO standard planes
so why not send them Jets to fly in too
we've been very clear and we've been
clear for a long time that when it comes
to the provision of military assistance
to Ukraine nothing is off the table what
is holding the west back why is there
that lag we've continued to be on the
forward Leading Edge of it and we're
providing things as quickly as we can
the Ukraine sees that we do respond and
then we Galvanize others to respond to
Russia have no pity for their own people
they keep throwing people into battle we
have pity and we protect our people and
we would not throw them onto the
battlefield we needed to prepare them
and that marked a different stage in the
war and now we're at the stagnation
phase
but is the ever more sophisticated and
deadly help being sent to Ukraine by the
UK and its allies leading to a slippery
slope towards a much wider War the
provision of extra weapons to Ukraine
does not in itself remind you
significantly increase the escalation
risks providing those weapons are not
used by Ukraine against the territory of
Russia itself challenged attacks like
these will be in Ukraine within a few
weeks so the government but to be
effective military experts say they need
air cover too which the ukrainians don't
have enough of so the logic towards
sending fighter jets is becoming
increasingly pressing
Logic the president hopes will be
persuasive when he takes his case to
allies on the continent next Dominic
wagorn Sky News Dorset